herzlich willkommen ja es gibt nach wie
vor nur wenige frauen die an den
schalthebeln der macht sitzen
warum ist das so und was können wir
dagegen tun
darüber spreche ich mit laura lässt sie
hat vor gut 20 jahren einen rat der
weltweit führenden politikerinnen
gegründet und hat also einen draht nach
ganz oben etwa zu angela merkel oder
auch theresa herzlich willkommen wäre
unsere welt eine bessere wenn mehr
frauen an der macht wären nun wie ein
professor einmal sagte mit frauen an den
hebeln der macht wäre unsere welt eine
andere
weil der weg dorthin einen kulturwandel
erfordert
wäre es anders wenn frauen 50 prozent
der führungskader oder 50 prozent
erfahren sie moderatorin ausmachten
ja ich glaube die dinge anders wäre es
besser wie auch emine über die
auswirkungen der französischen
revolution sagt man weiß es noch nicht
eine andere perspektive andere
erfahrungen
frauen leben anders in der welt als
männer sie sind nicht unbedingt
einfühlsame oder fürsorglicher aber sie
wissen vielleicht mehr über ihre
mitmenschen mit ihrer prägung durch die
heutige gesellschaft müssen sie
verstehen wie die dominante gruppe
funktioniert die macht elitär braucht
sich nicht um die andere gruppe zu
kümmern
umgekehrt aber schon frauen sind wohl in
der tendenz aufmerksam
ich tanze hier etwas um die frage wäre
es besser herum
es wäre sicher anders und einzelne
indikatoren auch wirtschaftlicher art
legen nahe dass die dinge tatsächlich
besser werden wie könnte es auch anders
sein wenn man den blickwinkel um die
fehlenden 50 prozent ergänzt muss das
resultat noch besser sein oder werden
über alters noch diskutieren in dieser
stunde
jetzt interessiert mich zuerst mal sie
selbst sind ja eine sehr erfolgreiche
frau sie haben an spitzenpositionen für
internationale firmen gearbeitet dafür
goldman sachs oder für boston consulting
sie haben herr vor gut 20 jahren ein rad
der weltweit führenden politikerinnen
gegründet und sind jetzt
generalsekretärin dieses council of
women's world leaders warum haben sie es
denn nach oben geschafft und viele
andere fragen die das möchten nicht
es fragt sich ob ich es an die spitze
geschafft habe aber ich hoffe ich konnte
bestimmte dinge verändern
eine andere sicht einbringen am meisten
gefällt mir wenn nach einer rede jemand
auf mich zukommt und mir sagt mensch so
habe ich mir das noch nie überlegt es
gefällt mir umso mehr wenn ich von
männern höre so wie sie das gesagt haben
habe ich noch nie darüber nachgedacht
ich wollte immer schon dinge verändern
in der geschäftswelt gehörte ich zu
denen die missstände feststellten
behoben und danach weiter zu der sinn
dessen was wir im leben tun erschließt
sich oft erst mit dem blick in den
rückspiegel wie sind wir dann gelangt wo
wir jetzt sind
so stand am anfang der gründung des
council of women's world leaders die
frage
was es braucht damit eine frau
präsidentin der usa werden könnte weil
es ja in den usa leider keine frau gab
die eine solche frage hätte beantworten
können beschloss ich eine der 15 frauen
zu treffen die an land anführten oder s
angeführt hatten keine ahnung weshalb
ich auf den gedanken gekommen war dass
es möglich wäre eine präsidentin oder
premierministerin zu treffen 90er jahren
92 96 haben diese 15 mächtigsten frauen
der welt dann getroffen um zu lernen was
es dann heißen würde für eine
präsidentin in den usa wie das wäre an
was die sozusagen mitbringen müsste
interessanterweise wie es mich keine der
15 starts frauen ab die ich für ein
interview angefragt hat marita sagte
melden sie sich wieder nachdem sie alle
anderen getroffen haben ich bin ziemlich
sicher dass sie dachte diese ich nie
wieder
und es war richtig spannend
sie glänzte er nicht unbedingt als regen
ist in aber sie war sehr interessant und
vor allem sehr wissbegierig was eine
wichtige führungsqualität ist
tatsächlich waren alle starts frauen
sehr neugierig auch in bezug auf das was
die anderen frauen mir gesagt hatten
durch diesen austausch so sich meine
interviews immer mehr in die länge
das war ziemlich faszinierend und aus
diesem waidhaus project wie das haben
sie dann diesen council of the world
leaders gegründet letztlich auch wo
heute über 70 mitgliederinnen und
mitglied also mitgliederinnen drin sind
welche erfahrungen also wie wie tauschen
sie sich aus wie oft treffen sie worüber
sprechen sie da in diesem rat wie sie
sich vorstellen können ist alles sehr
vertraulich weil dem council nebst
früheren auch amtierende staatslenker
rinnen angehört
von den 74 sind üblicherweise jeweils
zehn zwölf oder höchstens 14 im amt die
treffen sind privat aber wir arbeiten
auch mit anderen organisationen zusammen
wir organisieren anlässe während der uno
versammlungen oder im umfeld von anderen
organisationen an den zusammenkünften
tauschen sie sich über ihre jeweiligen
erfahrungen aus interessanterweise sagen
die frauen auch 20 jahre nach gründung
des kampfes immer noch dasselbe
überkritisch die stimme das haar die
kleidung die presse die medien immer
derselbe dass sie sich weniger fehler
erlauben können das im vergleich mit den
männern ein anderer maßstab gilt aber
kritisch werden die beurteilten
gegensatz zu den männern und gegen ja
auch oberflächlich das aussehen spielt
eine rolle
und was muss man als frau mitbringen
diesen führungspositionen angeblich hat
man das so scheint das schwieriger aus
dem männer wissen sie frauen müssen auch
viel mehr auf die reihe kriegen
es geht um die themen die auch sheryl
sandberg anspricht frauen können sich
nicht zu viele fehler leisten weil es
sonst sofort heißt typisch männer machen
doppelt so viele fehler und keiner merkt
solche dinge halt frauen dürfen nicht zu
selbstbewusst auftreten nun nicht
aggressiv zu wirken
sie müssen immer auch sympathisch sein
es ist nicht einfach gleichzeitig
sympathisch und energisch zu sein wenn
es nötig ist sich durchzusetzen oder für
das einzustehen woran man glaubt männer
müssen das nicht wenn sie mit
bestimmtheit auftreten findet man sie
vielleicht nicht sympathisch aber man
schätzt an ihre führungsqualität den
spielraum für frauen ist oft sehr klar
gemacht woher haben sie diese stärke und
diesen diesen mut entwickelt um dem
standzuhalten diesen widerständen ja
manchmal schaut man dem widerstand in
die augen und sagt wie ist das alles
mehr kommt da nicht ein bisschen sinn
für humor und die fähigkeit sich zu
distanzieren hilft wenn man angegriffen
wird mit der zeit und den erfahrungen
wächst ja auch das selbstvertrauen
man weiss wovon man spricht ich glaube
übrigens nicht dass es den frauen an
selbstvertrauen fehlt wie man oft hört
ich denke er sie sehen die realität
forderte eine frau ultimativ eine
gehaltserhöhung würde das vom chef wohl
als forschung funden und abgelehnt
werden ein mann hingegen kann problemlos
eine gehaltserhöhung fordern weil wir
sie natürlich verdient ich hatte oft das
selbstbewusste männer kleine länder
überfallen während selbstbewusste frauen
eine lohnerhöhung fordern
es ist schwierig die meisten starts
führerinnen wie ich getroffen habe haben
einen weg gefunden sich durch dieses
minenfeld zu schlängeln sie wissen wie
und oft hilft auch humor
sie können selbstbewusst auftreten und
andere ins gespräch mit einbeziehen
derzeit gelingt vier junge frauen ist es
am anfang oft schwierig in der schule
machen sie die hälfte der schülerschaft
im sport sind sie unter sich aber im
arbeitsumfeld kommen sie nun auf die
welt und dann muss man oft aus der
komfortzone heraus sagen sie half und
sie haben das gelernt auf eine reise
habe ich gelesen mit dem fahrrad
ich hab das sogar zweimal gemacht und
mich dabei ziemlich weit aus meiner
komfortzone heraus bewegt zuerst bin ich
mit dem fahrrad durch sibirien gefahren
wovon ich ihnen übrigens das war bevor
ich die lieder straff 1994
das gab mir vielleicht auch den mut die
staaten lenkerinnen zu treffen und dann
bereiste ich mit dem rad die
seidenstraße das war noch interessante
aber auch härter aber ich wollte ja auch
raus aus meiner komfortzone und andere
teile der welt sehen aber wie gesagt ich
rate ihnen davon ab wie wo stehen wir
dann heute sie überblicken ja sozusagen
denen die ganze welt wenn es um
gleichstellung geht mit ihrem rad sie
haben irgendwie draht zu ganz vielen
politikerinnen wie weit ist der weg noch
bis zur weltweiten gleichstellung der
geschlechter oder zumindest von mann und
frau
ich fürchte der weg ist immer noch
ziemlich weit
es lohnt sich die statistik an zuschauer
insbesondere den gender gap report den
gleichstellungsbericht man sieht dort
das sich bei den gesundheitsausgaben für
frauen und männer die lücke in fast
allen ländern geschlossen hat auch bei
der bildung ist das gefälle mehr oder
weniger verschwunden
in einzelnen ländern schließen sogar
mehr frauen als männer eine höhere
schule in politik und wirtschaft aber
wird die kluft nicht klein
viele von uns hatten die philosophische
zeugung das mit gesundheit und bildung
der übertritt in die arbeitswelt und in
die politik ganz natürlich folge würden
und die gleichstellung erreicht während
die anzahl jahre bis zur gleichstellung
steigt aber im forums bericht jahr für
jahr im moment ist man bei 217 jahren
das ist mehr als letztes jahr
das ist lange über 200 jahre einzelne
länder sind im ziel näher als andere
länder gehen also jetzt skandinavien
immer die gleichen beispiele schweden
estland norwegen was was machen die denn
ich nenne sie die nordischen nirvanas
wir alle möchten wissen was die da
machen und warum einige forscher und
akademiker begründen es mit den relativ
kleinen homogenen gesellschaften und der
starken rolle der gewerkschaften die
immer schon teil der politischen
landschaft waren in den nordischen
ländern und gleichstellung immer geliebt
haben interessanterweise liebten einige
dieser länder immer schon von der
fischerei die männer waren also elf
monate im jahr auf dem meer um zu
fischen
während sich die frauen zu hause um
alles kümmerte auch um das regieren und
die wirtschaft diese kultur bestand über
tausende jahre
diese länder sind zwar nicht perfekt
aber sicher besser als die meisten
anderen
sie verstehen offenbar die bedeutung von
gleichheit und nutzen mit ein paar
wenigen ausnahmen positive
diskriminierungs maßnahmen im parlament
zb
und einige dieser länder hatten als
erste eine 50 prozent quote für die
regierung anders als in den usa wo diese
funktion nicht aufgeteilt ist können
einige nordische länder sowohl die
funktion des präsidenten als auch die
des premierministers oft wird dann das
eher zeremonielle amt des
staatspräsidiums von einer frau
ausgeliebt während ein mann das exekutiv
amt des premiers besetzt damit sind die
menschen vertraut mit dem bild einer
frau in führungspositionen aus der
erfahrung der nordischen länder lassen
sich interessante schlüsse ziehen wo sie
das ansprechen eine frau an der spitze
in island zum beispiel ist das sehr früh
passiert die erste präsidentin eines
landes gewählt
ich muss den namen ablesen wie dies
viele porto dir etwas sie sind
befreundet mit ihren haben nach mit ihr
zusammen diesen rat gegründet
und ich war stand zu lesen dass
anscheinend die kleinkinder sich gar
nicht vorstellen konnten wie es ist dass
ein mann an der spitze ist weil wir
kannten das nicht anders wow killer
zählen auch sie war 16 jahre lang im amt
und damit die frau mit der weltweit
längsten regierungszeit
sie erzählt dass sie nach acht
amtsjahren bei reisen durchs land vom
achtjährigen ist selten gefragt wurde
und männer auch präsident sein könnten
in dieser vorbildfunktion und der
medienpräsenz liegt eine nicht zu
unterschätzende macht der symbole
heute haben sie übrigens eine frau als
premier ministerin über die vorbilder
werden wir ansprechen dass die
unglaublich wichtig sind natürlich und
in schweden habe ich gelesen wurde ein
feministische manifest von einer
nigerianischen autorin jane andalucia dj
tobi feminist wir sollten alle fenster
sein dass dieses büchlein das wurde an
alle 16 jährigen verteilt im ganzen land
wer so etwas in den usa auch denkbar die
antwort ja ihre botschaft ist richtig
und eindringlich wie der titel sagt
sollten wir alle feministen seien sowohl
männer wie frauen verdienen es ganze
menschen zu sein
sie argumentiert dass männer ebenso wie
frauen in den käfigen ihre rolle
gefangen
man versteht immer mehr was es bedeutet
immer stark sein zu müssen
nicht weinen zu dürfen sich stets zu
messen immer siegen zu müssen
das männliche gefühlsspektrum dadurch
kleiner
damit bin ich absolut einverstanden
sicher stecken frauen in cathy sie
müssen nett sein den richtigen heiraten
sich gedanken machen über männer
umgekehrt gilt das weniger aber die
männer sind eben auch gefangene ihrer
warum sollten männer nicht über dieselbe
bandbreite von emotionen verfügen die
frauen aber von der gesellschaft hören
sie weinen nicht du kannst wütend sein
aber die anderen gefühle darfst du nicht
wirklich zeigen umgekehrt ist den frauen
das wütend sein vermuten dahinter ist ja
oft eine biologische dass gesagt wird
männer sind anders aus natürlich bereits
simon die bucher verwies auf den
unterschied zwischen biologischem und
sozial ungerecht
zwischen sex und gender das mag vor
80.000 jahren oder so nützlich gewesen
seien als männer bisons erlegten um zu
überleben
es gibt aber heute nicht mehr so viele
wie sonst
also haben sich diese fähigkeiten
weiterentwickelt und an neue bedürfnisse
angepasst heute geht es um die
sachzwänge die für jedes geschlecht
bestehen
natürlich gibt es gewisse biologische
faktoren als ich durch sibirien adelte
waren die männer dank ihrer muskeln
ziemlich gut im bergfahren aber ich war
im flachen gelände viel besser ich ewig
weiter fahren konnte kamen die männer da
schon mal an eine grenze aufwärts hatte
ich das nachsehen
natürlich erklärt sich dass durch die
physiologischen gegebenheiten
das ist ja klar aber alles andere
vorüber an große oder simon bolivar
sprechen ist ein soziales konstrukt wie
man sich verhalten soll
wie man beurteilt wird und eben auch die
kriterien für eine gute
führungspersönlichkeit die
durchsetzungsstark und groß gewachsen
sein muss wie der einsame cowboy der in
den sonnenuntergang reitet oder könig
arthur der das schwert aus dem stein sie
in der heutigen welt kommt man damit
wohl aber nicht mehr wirklich weit diese
unbewussten vorurteile die in uns drin
sind das ist glaube ich eine große
herausforderung wenn es um
gleichstellung geht und dass das auch
schädlich sein kann für die männer diese
männlichkeitsvorstellungen das haben
jetzt ja jüngst auch amerikanische
psychologen ja gezeigt dass es
gesundheitsschädigend sein kann nicht
interessiert noch einmal die usa zwar
nur die kongress war und die hauptseite
waren
im letzten november da hat sich einiges
getan es waren irgendwie viele junge
frauen gewählt worden
nach zwei musliminnen 2 mit indigener
abstammung
macht das hoffnung wenn es so weitergeht
ist das definitiv eine gute entwicklung
es entspricht ja auch eher dem wahren
bild amerikas in seiner vielfalt
die oppositionsbewegung wurde durch die
art und weise wie diese regierung die
frauen wahrnimmt und behandelt
dynamisiert schienen frauen reicht es
vielleicht müssen wir danken es ist
einfacher geworden da geht das eine frau
präsident umgekehrt es wäre zu viel von
mir verlangt dankbar zu sein bei dem sie
aber philosophisch ist durch ihn etwas
sichtbar geworden
technologischer fortschritt und
innovation geschehen zuverlässig die
spanne zwischen geräte generationen wird
immer kürzer nicht sicher aber sind
kultureller fortschritt und wandel weil
technologie immer besser wird glauben
wir fälschlicherweise dass deshalb auch
die zivilisation sich immer weiter
entwickelt dabei ist selbst ein rückfall
ins mittelalter
die taliban haben es vorgemacht und
dabei modernste technologie genutzt
wir beobachten eine regression zur mitte
1 1 mitten nach dem extrem viele frauen
sind viel zu weit gekommen als dass sie
einen solchen archetyp hinnehmen könnten
der sie verhöhnt er macht sich zwar auch
über männer lustig aber sein umgang
frauen gegenüber ist doch sehr anders
frauen und insbesondere
afroamerikanerinnen motiviert anzutreten
das ist wichtig nur wenn sich mehr frau
unserer wahl stellen wird man auch mehr
frauen in der politik haben
deshalb war es toll zu sehen wie viele
frauen sich um ein amt beworben haben es
gab dafür auch noch einen anderen grund
frauen leisten nun doch seit einigen
jahren in allen funktionen dienst in der
armee gemäss titel sieben der
bürgerrechts gesetze haben frauen auch
ihren platz im sport das führte zu einer
großen gruppe von frauen in
führungspositionen unter den
kandidatinnen waren denn auch viele
veteranen die im militär aufgestiegen
denen kann man nichts vormachen
aber auch sie werden über kritisch
beurteilt in absoluten zahlen hinken wir
aber immer noch weit zurück der gender
gap report setzt uns auf rang 70 oder so
und weil die meisten länder im gegensatz
zu uns positive diskriminierung
mechanismen haben werden wir weiter
zurückfallen für die schweiz geht es ja
ein bisschen ähnlich ist also wir stehen
euch nicht allzu schlechter aber sind
irgendwie auf diesen global gender gap
report diesem gleichstellungs index
abgerutscht und vom 28 platz und wenn es
um diese gläserne decke geht also um das
phänomen dass frei und zwar arbeiten
erwerbsquote ist hoch aber sie schaffen
oder kommen nicht an die ganz an die
position ganz oben leider also eine
gläserne decke ist angeben da sind wir
weit unter dem durchschnitt wie kann man
diese gläserne decke durchbrechen
ich muss vorausschicken dass ich nicht
an anne claire seiner decke glaube es
handelt sich wohl eher um eine dicke
schicht männer das gilt also nicht glas
zu durchbrechen sondern diese dicke
schicht männer es ist schwierig
bekanntermaßen wurde das
frauenstimmrecht
in der schweiz erst sehr spät angeführt
aber in ihrer regierung wechselt die
rolle des präsidenten und eine anzahl
unserer mitglieder hatte dieses amt inne
dieses rotierende system scheint also zu
funktionieren
ich weiß nicht welche machtfülle damit
einher geht aber es ist ein hohes amt
aber vor auch in der wirtschaft glaube
ich haben wir eigentlich nachholbedarf
also jetzt in der politik sicherlich
auch frauen in der wirtschaft sind
einfach an den spitzenpositionen immer
noch wenige frauen und sie selbst haben
ja lange in der wirtschaft gearbeitet
und ich habe es gesagt bei boston
consulting und so weiter gibt es
irgendwelche tricks oder irgendwelche
spielregeln die man ändern kann damit
das irgendwie vorwärts geht
[Gelächter]
den trieb suchen wir alle den schalter
der die glühbirnen anknipst niemand
scheint ihm bislang gefunden zu haben
aber man kennt doch ein paar dinge die
funktionieren
die schweiz ist in vielerlei hinsicht
ein konservatives land ihre wirtschaft
hängt stark von finanzinstituten ab die
an sich sehr konservativ sind aber auch
die industrie branche ist wohl eher
konservativ gibt es in der schweiz
quoten vier verwaltungsräte ja also noch
nicht gesetzlich das wird diskutiert so
weit ich war es im parlament derzeit
kommt jetzt zum ständerat noch nicht
klar
ja ja das hat in einigen ländern
geholfen
genau wegen zb konnte man damit in den
verwaltungsräten eine kritische masse
von 40 prozent frauen erreichen und hat
geholfen
ja dort hat sie am längsten bestand
man weiß seitdem dass sich dadurch auch
die grünen prozesse verändern
so hat man herausgefunden dass viele
frauen die verwaltungsrats informationen
ließen die männer scheinen jetzt die
unterlagen auch zu lesen
allein die präsenz von frauen hat also
das verhalten der männer verändert
gemischte teams sind effizienter
effektiver
ja ich glaube gemischte teams sind am
besten von dieser studie zu norwegen
weiß man dass männer bei verwaltungsrats
entscheidungen er die kurzfristigen
auswirkungen berücksichtigt während
frauen eher die langfristigen folgen
sahen der bestmögliche verwaltungsrat
befasst sich sowohl mit den kurs wie
auch den langfristigen konsequenzen die
männer achten in der tendenz auf die
folgen für die shareholder die frauen
auf die stakeholder angestellten die
umwelt die gesellschaft der bestmögliche
verwaltungsrat fühlt sich sowohl dem
aktionariat wie auch den ansprüchen
verpflichtet ist ich bin eine starke
verfechterin diese ausgewogenheit
es gibt aber ein wahrnehmungsproblem bei
der vertretung die forscherin geena
davis hat herausgefunden dass bei einer
tatsächlichen vertretung von 20 prozent
männer einen frauenanteil von 50 prozent
erstaunlich nicht bleiben wenn der
frauenanteil 30 prozent ausmacht sehen
die männer 60 prozent eine mehrheit also
obwohl dies nicht erfahren
ich meine eine andere sache ist noch
diese diese lohn ungleich dieser
ungleichheit ist auch immer noch gibt
bis zu 20 prozent für diesen fragen
weniger an spitzenpositionen überall
auch noch in der schweiz
und da habe ich mich gefragt woran liegt
das und viele sagen ja es liegt daran
hand an den den kindern also wie man
irgendwie dass frauen kinder haben
können und dann besteht hat die die die
gefahr dass dann diese frauen eine
auszeit nehmen müssen usw
das heißt bräuchte ja es auch mehr
eltern förderung anstatt frauenförderung
ist das vielleicht ganz entscheiden die
kinder die familie
es ist nicht die entscheidende faktor in
der forschung zu lohnungleichheit
rechnet man die stellung und die
familien aspekte heraus aber die kluft
zwischen männern und frauen besteht
trotzdem weiter
frauen scheinen teilweise abgestraft zu
werden wenn sie mehr geld verlangen in
großbritannien hat man möglicherweise
hierfür eine lösung gefunden unternehmen
dort müssen transparent über
lohnunterschiede berichten
ich empfehle dass der schweiz auch die
sender werden bloß gestellt
eine unterschiedliche bezahlung kann
auch zu politischen und rechtlichen
problemen führen einzelne länder wie
schweden kamen ein gutes beispiel
gesetzt mit einem obligatorischen
gleichlangen vater und
mutterschaftsurlaub das ist richtig denn
sonst übernehmen frauen einen übergroßen
teil der kinderbetreuung und buddhismus
von diesen pflichten werden die männer
begünstigt und kommen leichter zum
erfolg bei einer teilung der
betreuungspflichten wäre dies nicht der
fall und auch das stigma unter den
frauen mit kindern oft leiden viele weg
frauen wird schnell vorgeworfen
sie setzten sich nicht genügend ein was
überhaupt nicht stimmt
überdies ist es auch gut für die männer
die erziehungsarbeit mitzugestalten und
windeln zu wechseln
wir haben vorher also ich habe über
diese tricks gesprochen die es
vielleicht gibt und es gibt eine
schweizer verhaltensforscherin iris poth
die an der harvard kennedy school lehrt
und sie ein buch geschrieben what works
und sie war auch schon bei uns in der
sendung
und sie hat ein interessantes beispiel
gebracht wo das funktioniert wo man
diese gläserne decke leichter sprechen
kann und nimmt das beispiel von
amerikanischen orchester
und wir schauen uns das große
miteinander was die amerikanischen
orchester in den 70er jahren gemacht
haben ist ziemlich interessant ein paar
große orchester haben die musiker und
musikerinnen gefragt sich hinter einem
vorhang zu bewerben und auch hinter
einem vorhang zu spielen und das war ist
ein interessantes beispiel auch
tatsächlich forschung nicht ein beispiel
ein interessantes beispiel weil das
eingeführt wurde obwohl die dirigenten
tatsächlich nur männer zu der zeit
gedacht haben dass bestimmte vorhänge
keine rolle spielen weil sie natürlich
und die selektionskommission nun auf die
musik hört das sind da die ökonomischen
anreize eigentlich völlig klar man will
ja gute musik natürlich und auch die
branchen anreiz in dem sinne sind klar
man will ja nicht jemanden anstellen
weil er ein weißer mann ist zum beispiel
und jetzt was auch die vorhänge gezeigt
haben ist dass die wahrscheinlichkeit
dass dann frauen in eine zukünftige
runde vorwärtskommen um 50 prozent
erhöht wird und diese vorhänge haben
heute die anzahl der frauen und der
anteil der fernsehkritiker der anteil
der frauen in diesen auch gestern von 5%
1970 ab heute fast 40 prozent erhöht ja
es erstaunlich was die überhaupt zur
ökonomie da irgendwie erzählt und wie
man das irgendwie auch ändern kann und
sie was machte danach vorschläge wie man
das in unternehmen
umsetzen kann etwa mit mit
blindbewerbungen usw
aber mich hat interessiert diese
unbewussten vorurteile also das was in
unserem kopf drin ist dass das eine
ungeheure macht hat und es gibt ja diese
untersuchungen die zeigen ein und
derselbe lebenslauf und vanendert den
namen des mannes und in einer frau jo
howard oder heidi und spielten eine
rolle ob das männlich oder weiblich ist
je nachdem
liest man diesen leben schaffen sagt ein
sympathischer erfolgreicher mann oder
irgendwie so eine aggressive kraut
befreit total unsympathisch
was macht man dagegen wie geht man gegen
diese stereotype vor iris die ich
übrigens gut kenne hat wohl aus
zeitgründen etwas nicht erwähnt
tatsächlich mussten die frauen auch ihre
schuhe ausziehen und sich von einem mann
mit schuhen über den teppich losen boden
begleiten die annahme war also dass alle
kandidaten männer während alle genossen
also einen kleinen wettbewerbsvorteil
niemand litt unter einem versteckten
nachteil wenn wir über die
benachteiligung der frauen sprechen
vergessen wir oft dass männer
tatsächlich begünstigt werden
ich habe noch nie einen führenden
manager getroffen der eingestanden hätte
seine position auch über produktion
erreicht zu haben
niemand würde so etwas zu geben vielmehr
betont man seine leistung wird dass es
nur die besten nach oben schaffen ihres
beispiel zeigt dass dem nicht so ist und
weil es so interessant ist sei noch
angeführt dass auch der anteil nicht
weiter nicht europäische orchester
musiker in sinfonieorchestern ansteigt
warum weil auch hier die annahme bestand
dass ein chinesischer oboist brahms bach
und beethoven unmöglich verstehen können
dafür braucht doch sicher einen weißen
europäer
naja einen deutsch
das beispiel ist bewusst gewählt der
weltweit beste oboist januar solo oboist
im new york philharmonic orchestra muss
ich bis heute die frage gefallen lassen
ob er als chinese brahms überhaupt
verstehen können hier hat der vorhang
die gleiche funktion
am anfang des vorhangs stand übrigens
die überlegung dass studenten nicht
durch ihre lehrenden bevorzugt werden
sollten
erst danach entdeckte man die parallele
zu den frauen
ich mag das beispiel weil es zeigt dass
man die wirklichen fähigkeiten und die
leistung erst dann sieht wenn man das
unbewusste ausklang
tatsächlich versuchen viele
organisationen neue wege zu finden mit
blind verfahren und ähnlichem
aber es bleibt schwierig denn je höher
man kommt in einer organisation des
tores subtile wird es bei den meisten
unternehmen wohl auch in der schweiz ist
das verhältnis auf an trittstufe
ziemlich ausgewogen
das problem kommt später auf der
karriereleiter ganz berühmtes buch von
facebook 22 13 erschienen linie bleiben
die frauen sich reinzuhängen und zu
sagen ihr müsst auch etwas dafür tun
wie stehen sie zu dieser these nun sie
hat den leuten die augen geöffnet für so
einiges das buch ist gut recherchiert
und überzeugte unter anderem mit der
erkenntnis dass selbstbewusste frauen
nur akzeptiert werden wenn sie auch
sympathisch rüberkommen
kritisiert wurde sie weil sie als
vermögen der weiße frau abgehoben sei
von den vielen frauen die weder das eine
noch das andere sind und die gleichen
lohn fordern um über die runden zu
kommen
ich unterscheide zwischen dem saatkorn
und dem boom der einzelnen person und
dem was sie tun muss um voranzukommen
und der institution welche die
bedingungen dafür schafft dass die leute
sich entwickeln können
das konzept der laut quakenden ente aus
meinem buch zeigt das ganz gut glaube
ich wenn ich das hier erwähnen da einige
menschen haben gelernt dass nur das
quietschen der rat geholt wird dass man
kann so seine stimme erheben muss um zu
bekommen was man will
amerikanischer männer haben das
verinnerlicht den japanern wurde
beigebracht dass der herausstehende
nagel eingehämmert wird man sagt also
besser nicht frauen wurde ein gebraucht
nur nettes zu sagen und die chinesen
wissen dass man auf die laut quaken der
interski stberg jetzt schaut ja genau
alle sagen sie wollen diversität und
haben dann ein rad eine ente eine nadel
und was nettes und wer spricht nur das
rad an anderen hat die großmutter
beigebracht zu schweigen
es braucht also eine organisation die
das merkt dass ich wirklich den augen
öffnen dieses wundervollen buchs dass es
auch um diese vielfalt geht also es ist
ja eine sache zu sagen in einem
unternehmen braucht es beide
geschlechter aber es braucht eben auch
verschiedene kulturen verschiedene
personen mit verschiedenen alter zum
beispiel verschiedener herkunft und
unterschiedlichen hobbys das kann ganz
entscheidend sein sagen sie ist und
überall da kann eben diskriminierung
stattfinden
absolut ich nenne das die arche noah
theorie der diversität gemäß der
vielfalt erreicht ist wenn man ein paar
von allem hat man merkt dann aber
schnell dass man ein problem hat wenn
die giraffe auf das zebra schaut und
sich wundert wie es mit diesem kurzen
hals bilden etwas zustande kriegen zwei
von allem reicht nicht es braucht die
leute die sich mit kulturellen
unterschieden auskennen in
organisationen die unbedingt
unterschiedlicher nationalitäten in der
belegschaft haben wollen
stelle ich auf die frage wissen sie was
die briten wirklich über die franzosen
denken oder die inder über die pakistani
oder die japaner über die chinesen oder
die australier über die neuseeländer die
kiwis ich weiß nicht wen man in der
schweizer werden konnte aber da gibt
sicher auch wie man hat nun also all die
unterschiedlichen nationalitäten aber
was denken die alle übereinander income
pro die kanadische premierminister in
sagte einmal sehen die amerikaner die
kanadier einfach als unbewaffnete
amerikaner mit krankenversicherung von
einer führungsperson sie sind ja auch
eine expertin für für leadership also
wie man ein team eine unternehmung
führt was muss jetzt aus dieser
perspektive getan werden damit diese
vielfalt auch gelebt wird und nicht bloß
irgendwie man von jedem eine person
darin liegt die herausforderung die
sprachenfrage ist ein beispiel in
amerikanischen firmen ist englisch die
unternehmenssprache in indien stelle ich
oft fest dass die kollegen dort
ausufernd antwort
als ich einmal nach fragte wieso die
antwort so lang ausfiel
da kam ich zu hören dass in der schule
die note mit der länge der antwort
steigt manager in new york sind anders
als der kollege in mobile und das muss
man alles wissen das heißt man muss den
kulturellen hintergrund kennen sie sagen
man muss die großmutter erkennen
hab ich gelesen dass man muss richtig
welche welche werte einem vermittelt
wurden von zu herzen
ja unbedingt
aber es ist vielschichtig indische
dialekte sind sogenannte high kontext
sprachen die antwort umfasst den
gesamten kontext der frage
amerikanisches englisch ist mit gewissen
regionalen unterschieden an elo kontext
sprache präzise auf den punkt das
problem ist dass angehörige von kulturen
mit starkem oder schwachen kontext in
bezug auf einander vorbei reden wer die
frage nicht knapp und präzise
beantwortet wird dann als dumm angesehen
während der andere als unhöflich
empfunden wird es ist also nicht so sehr
die unterschiedlichkeit als solche die
problematisch ist sondern wie wir sie
wahrnehmen wenn jemand anders ist
denken wir mit dem stimmt etwas nicht es
geht um die wahrnehmung und jetzt ist es
so jetzt im moment erleben wir ich
möchte ein bisschen einen schritt
zurücktreten erleben wir auch einen
backlash in gewisser weise in sachen
gleichstellung also wir haben irgendwie
donald trump putin erdogan usw
wir haben irgendwie viele männer auch
die sich in ihrer männlichkeit irgendwie
verletzt beängstigt fühlen aber nicht
nur männer es geht es gibt auch frauen
die die sagen die sache mit der
gleichstellung das geht zu weit und ein
beispiel in der schweiz ist die
moderatorin und video bloggerin tamara
werden und wir schauen uns ganz kurz
haben was sie zu sagen frauen sind in
den chefetagen unterrepräsentiert das
ist eine tatsache den grund dafür aber
mit systematischer chancenungleichheit
und diskriminierung zu verknüpfen ist
meines erachtens falsch
frauen haben heute zumindest in
westlichen industrieländern nicht
weniger berufliche chancen als männer
sie haben von anfang an die gleichen
karrieremöglichkeiten sie können jedes
fach studieren jeden beruf ausüben
eine frau kann arrangeurin werden
wissenschaftlerinnen bundesrätin
kanzlerin präsidentin
ja ja so war ihre meinung und sie sagt
auch die frauen sollten endlich raus
kommen aus dieser opferrolle und das ist
einfach nehmen das hat man nach gehört
im nachgang zu tun wo dann die
gegenstimme wurde ein paar sachen dazu
das ist ihre meinung dieser unbenommen
in 20 jahren nachdem sie andere
erfahrungen gemacht hat wird sie
vielleicht anders reden
sie sieht nur den einen aspekt wo frauen
in die arbeitswelt eintreten und hat
wohl noch nicht erfahren was dann mit
ihnen geschah
ich kann nicht abstreiten dass es einen
bergpreis gegeben hat umgekehrt könnte
der pendelschlag in die andere richtung
darauf hinweisen dass sich die dinge für
ein
ohne wandel kein wackler fortschritt
verläuft nicht linear sondern
schrittweise und oft geht man auch einen
schritt zurück es lohnt sich auch zu
fragen wer vor machtverlust betroffen
ist für viele männer und auch ein paar
frauen stimmt der status quo
ich finde es deprimierend dass nebst
vielen männern auch frauen an den
bestehenden geschlechterrollen
festhalten wollen
das erklärt die frage dahinter ist ja
warum sich menschen ändern nach tokio
die das ändern sich die menschen nur aus
drei gründen angst eigeninteresse und
ihre schmerz gewinn oder vision wird es
mir weh tun wenn ich mich nicht
verändere
wenn ich nicht abspecken zum beispiel
was gewinne ich wenn ich mich verändere
oder habe ich eine vision wohin sich die
welt bewegen sollte das wäre eine
haltung für führungspersönlichkeiten
manche menschen wollen den veränderungs
märz absolut vermeiden
der bug was überrascht mich also nicht
wirklich
ich werde oft nach den fortschritten
gefragt
der frühere premierminister
großbritanniens hatte dazu eine anekdote
er habe boris jelzin angerufen als der
noch an der macht war und ihn gefragt
boris sag mir in einem wort wie es in
russland läuft und die als in st gut
kannst du das etwas ausführen und mir in
zwei worten sagen wie es in russland
läuft die halten antwortete nicht gut
wenn sie mich also fragen wo wir stehen
liebe ich irgendwo dazwischen aber
interessant war schon zu wissen was
methoden die diese bewegung die sitzung
sei gut eingelebt und was die aus ihrer
sicht bewegt hat
und heute noch bewirkt nun auf der einen
seite hat sie sichtbar gemacht was heute
immer noch realität für frauen darstellt
sexuelle belästigung diskriminierung und
ohnmacht angesichts des übermäßigen
machtgefälles all das ist offenkundig
insbesondere das rüpelhafte verhalten
gewisser männer ohne zu generalisieren
sie würden das nie tun hoffe ich doch
zumindest aber vor allem männer in hohen
positionen haben nicht selten das gefühl
sie können sich alles herausnehmen
dafür war es gut es gab aber auch
rückschläge aus der sorge über
situationen in denen aussage gegen
aussage steht
das hatte unbeabsichtigte konsequenzen
wie die nach vizepräsident pence
benannte regel sich nie alleine mit
einer frau in einem raum aufzuhalten
oder ohne seine ehefrau mit einer
anderen frau zum dinner zu gehen genau
darum geht die männer weigern sich jetzt
mentoren von frauen zu sein oder sich an
sozialer anlässe begleiten zu lassen
oder mit ihnen zu reisen
es handelt sich um das dritte im new
yorker gesetz von aktion und reaktion
und genau diese gegen kraft lässt sich
jetzt beobachten
das ist potenziell brandgefährlich in
einem podiumsgespräch dass ich kürzlich
leitete fragte ich einen ceo was er
machen würde wenn ein leitender manager
sich weigerte frauen zu betreuen oder
sie zum lunch oder auf reisen
mitzunehmen und der ceo sagte nun sie
sollten sich schlicht an
dessen verhalten anstand ist auch eine
fundamentale regel in der westlichen
welt philosophisch gesehen aber ja der
berg lässt sich nicht bestreiten
vorher sprachen wirtschaftliche gründe
für frauen und diversität
es war moralisch richtig und gut fürs
geschäft heute fürchtet man
reputationsrisiken und imageschäden
bewegung war ja auch in vereinen
sozialen medien also hat das ganze
angefangen und mich würde interessieren
jetzt ihren blick auf die
digitalisierung als ganzes ist das jetzt
für die gleichstellung und für die
frauen eine eine chance was da auf uns
zukommt dieser radikale wandel unserer
gesellschaft mit digitalisierung
automatisierung und haben auch das ist
vertrag künstliche intelligenz beruht
auf algorithmen wenn die zu 90 prozent
von männern geschrieben werden bilden
sie wiederum eine bestimmte weltsicht ab
hatte nicht facebook kein problem damit
dass schwarze gesichter negativ
kommentiert worden
jemand hatte dies im algorithmus so
angelegt man muss genau hinschauen
auch bei den social media gibt es gut
und nicht gut
frauen werden oft geträumt und belästigt
wenn sie ihre feministische haltung
offenlegen
es besteht die gefahr dass sie durch
zwischenrufe zum schweigen gebracht
werden
[Musik]
wer mit ihnen jetzt zum schluss noch auf
ein anderes phänomen zu sprechen kommt
wir haben über diesen backlash
gesprochen und
über soziale medien und youtube ist auch
vertreten und da gibt es phänomene etwa
den kanadischen psychologen jürgen
peterson der viele männer anspricht die
in ihrer männlichkeit auch verunsichert
sind
er leugnet dass es ein dass wir in einer
gesellschaft leben die von männern
dominiert ist den leuten dass es ein
patriarchat gibt und möchte mich einen
ganz kurzen stelle anschauen
provokative überrascht
die thesen aber
erreicht hunderte von millionen von
menschen
unglaubliche resonanz überrascht sie das
nicht wirklich
man kann sich pseudo fakten immer so
zurecht legen wie man will
bei der aussage dass mehr männer im
gefängnis sind muss man nach den gründen
fragen also auf die eigentlichen
ursachen zurück gehen natürlich sterben
mehr männer in kriegen weil bis vor zwei
jahren frauen gar nicht zu
kampfeinheiten zugelassen bei diese
statistik löst sich also in luft auf er
hörte die frage nach dem kapital und den
machtpositionen nicht einmal weil das
nicht seiner weltsicht entspricht oder
der botschaft die er aus senden will er
spricht die an denen durch die
verschiebung der machtverhältnisse ihr
weltbild abhanden gebaut
es geht dabei nicht nur um gegen
schlechter frage sondern auch um rasse
und sexuelle orientierung attribute der
privilegierung drohen plötzlich
wegzufallen
die globalisierung hat zu
wirtschaftlichen missständen geführt
deren wir uns annehmen müssen
es sind stellen im produktionssektor
verloren gegangen und menschen leiden
darunter
wie können diese menschen umgeschult
werden anstatt zu provozieren sollte man
diese fragen sachlich angehen
ungeachtet seiner motive schützt die
amerikanische verfassung sein
meinungsäusserungsfreiheit darf sagen
was er will
außer feuer zu rufen in einem voll
besetzten kino erscheint die
aufmerksamkeit sehr zu genießen
jeder lieder hat sein archiv eine
geschichte die er lernen erzählt damit
sucht der anklang bei seiner
gefolgschaft
er hat seine nische gefunden seine
anhängerschaft unterliegt einem
bestätigungs fehler
sie sind damit nicht allein denn ich
bereits von etwas überzeugt bin und
darin bestätigt werde
blende ich alles aus was diese
überzeugung zuwiderläuft und halte mich
an das was mich in meinem glauben
bestätigt man kennt das vom autofahren
was sagt ein mann wenn er sieht dass
seine frau einen dummen fehler gemacht
hat typisch frau wie stümperhaftigkeit
der fünf männer hat er natürlich nicht
gesehen
man hat so seine vorgefassten meinungen
und filtert die realität entsprechend
seine haltung
genau das tut er wir sind leider schon
am ende der zeit ich habe sehr viel
gelernt vor allem dass gleichstellung im
kopf anfängt das zeigt dass das letzte
beispiel ich möchte ihnen ganz herzlich
danken für dieses gespräch
[Musik]